who's this [__] wow I'm not familiar oh
is this the girl that was exposed by the
quartering
who by the way doesn't know who we are
apparently yeah lying ass [__]
I don't know you mean who's quartering
oh I'm sorry boring Jeremy not to be
confused with Jeremy boring from the
daily wire who was also boring it was
also boring but it's not the same guy
at least he's grown-up boring yeah at
least Jeremy boring has grown-up boring
so it's boring Jeremy not boring Jeremy
boring okay all right okay so boring
Jeremy is the Funko Pop doll and the big
[__] adult baby uh Jeremy boring is
the guy that would still be boring
because if you had dinner with him he'd
be like I'll have one white wine
spritzer I'm driving yeah man I want to
go nuts
um
well lower calories quarter Rings back
on Twitter
um Paul got [__] banned not just
banned permanently suspended for his
joke and then he got and then he just
got brought back today and then defango
got popped Stefano defango just got
popped
um he'll probably be back I mean some of
this [__] seems to be sticking so that's
a good sign and the joke that got our
good friend Adonis Paul uh popped was I
and I'll read it for you I too became a
set of uh became a victim of sex
trafficking when somebody stole my
avatar once I still have nightmares
about it the horrors of someone online
using my non-nude photo that is why I
support at Eliza blue I also got sex
traffic once when they got my order
wrong at Wendy's
ah
he deserves to be suspended
him for that
um so a couple things have happened
since we last talked about it that
Twitter you saw that Twitter safety
person came out
uh and her tweet basically uh uh what
was God damn it Virgie can you get that
tweet for me and just read it please
thank you thank you so yeah so the head
of like that it was like the head of
Twitter safety or one of the people in
Twitter safety again Elon Musk has 100
kept his mouth shut and he's been
tweeting so it ain't like he's been busy
and I support that so what I would say
is make sure you use the hashtag hashtag
uh elizablue Elon that way people know I
like that yes
Eliza blue Elon that way people know so
I'm stealing Chris Jericho's gimmick of
having 19 different gimmicks and you're
stealing his gimmick of just trying to
force hashtag yeah that's right multiple
ones I'm doing that shots yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I have another one brother man
the other guys who's not using it
nobody's going hey guys
while we're talking using that he's just
not using his legs no one's watching
speaking of Jericho I have a new song
coming out it's called Pontius oh I like
that okay so I got you on that tweet
okay so who is this person again Ella
Irwin who is I guess the trust and
safety now yeah yeah I guess she's had a
trust in safety in the past two weeks
we've suspended multiple accounts and or
restricted content causing confusion for
users unfortunately we can't answer
questions or share details about
specific users and account actions but
here are some things that can lead to
these types of actions
uh she goes on to say first we will
suspend accounts for threats or
incitement of violence this includes for
example blah blah blah this is not
anything to do with it we've had to
suspend accounts remove documentaries
videos tweets and photos recently when
the proper reporting process was
followed people often disagree with
their actions and don't have full
context but we still have to take action
no they don't they don't have to take
action as Nick Arcata pointed out unless
there's an active like order by a court
or something you don't have to do
anything only the only time you can do
it is like if law enforcement does
contact you and say hey this is like a
[__] thing right now whatever then
they'll take it down but not when you
just people go this they're posting a
video of me that was publicly known for
years and it's bullying and it's mean
uh I've the the the last two that are
relevant to this thread which are kind
of yeah these issues are complex and
often resolved in court
we don't determine who in a legal
criminal case is ultimately right or
wrong but we will continue to ensure we
protect users comply with local laws and
remove content when required
um when did that happen well
here's the thing not only that but this
is on all out Blitz she tweeted
something Eliza blue tweeted something
like thanking YouTube and thanking
Twitter and thanking WorldStarHipHop by
the way the same people that she accused
yeah can you can you read that one just
read it just read that one I have the
screenshot of the email though that I
have
um so while I pull that up that's like
if you were if you were like a kid and
they filmed child porn of you and then
the people that profited from the child
point of view took it down from a
website and you thanked them like thank
you for taking down that child porn
video of me it's like no you'd still be
like no they're [__] trafficked me
right like when you like it's the whole
thing but my point is if she's such an
advocate of of such an advocate of
people why isn't she she should be
naming names immediately hey this so and
so at World Star Hip Hop trafficked me
or so and so rappers trafficked me but
they did and we're about to get that
into a second so we're about to get into
even I got you on the yeah what did she
say what did she say she said I have
been sexually exploited in multiple ways
like digitally I added that part I'd
like to think world star for removing a
video depicting me on Wednesday of this
week I'd like to thank Google and
YouTube for removing the video on
Wednesday it's weird I'd like to thank
Twitter and Twitter safety
now
I hold on here because I have a little I
have a [__] idiot I closed it uh
let's see here so this guy uh this guy
here uh Evie Warner I think it's it's a
kind of I don't know somebody named Evie
Warner on Twitter I'm sorry I apologize
probably a chick yeah but anyway uh Evie
Warner on Twitter emailed of course
which is the right thing to do by the
way emailed
um World Star Hip Hop
and uh this is what they said ready
this is a d at world's hot City but
Daniel cotton World Tour hip-hop she was
paid for this video and we own full
rights anything further can be addressed
via legal thank you now not only that
she she got she's claiming that that
YouTube took it down YouTube didn't take
it down to prove that she was right
if you look at the video I think we
mentioned this Friday but it was a
privacy complaint privacy can play
YouTube automatically to automatically
because it's happened to us
automatically takes it down and they
have like I think it's what 14 days or
something like that two weeks kind of
like the copy right there yeah it's kind
of similar right so no world star is
going to fight this because and if
you're Worldstar you have to because
you're accusing them of being sex
traffickers yeah that's insane so some
stuff before we get into even more I
want to remind people of this
um
by the way I also want to point out that
she wasn't [__] right until November and
December is when she really blew up
and she was doing that was when she did
Tim Poole and all these other shows like
these guys like Astro terifter they
built her up and now they're not even
like retracting her appearance or any of
the things she said like people like Tim
Poole are staying out of it so Tim Poole
helped AstroTurf this [__] and now that
in the entertain [__] she blew up
silence is violence Marsh oh here's the
Andrew Tate by the way the entertaining
perfect perfect Segway because that's
exactly what he's getting to next oh God
this this is great because I remembered
this and actually went back and I
screenshotted this because I remember
this tweet first off in April of 20
April 2022 she said yes I'm looking into
the Andrew Tate situation I had never
heard of him before and there's a lot of
information to go over somebody asked
her hey any updates on your assessment
this is in July I can't talk about it
once I take on a case I'm not allowed to
speak week on it till it goes to
practice so what are you a [__]
secret agent now you're [__] yeah
your detective is an active
investigation so so the particular
individual it's literally [__] hey
I'm working on this sex trafficking case
oh really what's going on can you fill
us in actually I can't talk about it
quiet quiet guy gets caught it was me I
did it this is the day and this is the
day that Andrew Tate uh what what this
this is a December 29th uh 2022 the day
Andrew Tate was arrested by remaining
authorities I am currently not a liberty
to speak about Andrew Taylor's brother I
have been for me I haven't been for many
months that's all I'm gonna say about
that right now if you DM me and ask me
about it I'll block you period as if she
two things
I'm loving this as if she had any sort
of pull anywhere to make anything like
that happen that's all [__] [__]
no bro she's got contacts at the
Romanian government I put that Meme I
made in the in the in the prep bag oh
yeah I know I already got a pole okay
um and
and uh let's see here
so uh uh where where'd you put it oh I
just put in the [__] prep bag okay
here it is uh
that's Frozen's prep bag
um
all right the PS yes Pepsi did make a
handy figured her out Marsh there it is
ah yeah that's the system yeah uh phase
one tweet that you're working on human
trafficking case phase two question mark
phase three take credit for the results
so
um this is uh uh all right here we go
this is her
I think it's a podcast or some book or
some [__] I don't know talking about the
World Star Hip-Hop video that she
claimed
that she was human trafficked it was
against her will
stop video I was a size 8
. you really try to unwicker yourself
when you started wearing Tiaras and
cowboy hats on hotep huh
I'm like they have it so skinny but it
was a summer I was doing a lot you know
but yeah I mean honestly for one
I was blessed to work with one of the
dopest directors in the game like does
that sound like somebody who was sex
trafficked
wowed that video and it got pulled down
it should be [__] re-uploaded right
it's almost like if your [__] got pulled
for a privacy complaint it should be
back up huh
and Virgie took that [__] personally it
kind of did it's but it's like okay
so
this chick [__] even if she wasn't
grifting on human trafficking even if we
weren't all hating her at this point
right now in time just listening to her
I want to [__] stab her in the
eyeball but the the way yeah like with
the dope with director yo and I was like
yo I'm so skinny that yeah shut up shut
up
um the I'm surprised you could hear her
because she sounds like every stripper
in the world in Mercury she has they
speak at a certain frequency that merch
could block out yeah
I'm like I'm like the I'm like the
horror equivalent of like if you just
heard like tweeting outside and I went
yeah that's a Brazilian cockatoo
so tell you how long you tell you how
[__] tall her pumps are yeah so she's
so uh Eliza Eliza has a great tipped
African hummingbird yeah how do you know
that like I don't know man I'm really
around birds for a long time
video God literally like if you look at
his resume I was so blessed this is the
other issue man is is it like people are
getting popped and getting kicked off of
not just Twitter not just YouTube but
also and to be fair people are getting
videos are getting popped on Rumble and
that's happening and I'm not gonna sit
here and try to pretend like it's not it
is an issue and I hope that [__] gets
[__] straight now because I don't
like it that makes me real uncomfortable
all right Virgie we Virgie re-uploaded
re-uploaded the rap video virtually
re-upload the rap video and it'd be one
thing if the video was taken down
because World Star Hip Hop owns the
video and they said that's mine they
dmca ate him 100 understand that nobody
would even blink an eye but the problem
is is that it was taken down for other
reasons and it was taking that if it's
taken down the legal complaint then that
then it does tie the hands on the
platform right to a certain extent and
somebody's not to take this [__] to
court and the problem with that is is
that now the prop the issue is with all
of these platforms everyone that's
[__] censoring this [__] the [__]
problem with this is like so all I need
to do is say any video someone's playing
of me is sex trafficking and then that's
it or they'll be the kicked off of every
platform they're going to be demonetized
they're going to lose every I just one
understands to happen how does this
[__] have this much [__] power I'm
sorry I'm sorry but if you got a privacy
complaint for this video all right if
you got a privacy complaint for the
[__] World Star Hip-Hop video that
they pulled down and you honored that
request then you didn't watch that video
at all you did not look at the [__]
request you did not look at the [__]
video that was being that was being
brought up in question you you couldn't
have it's a [__] music video where
she's shaking her ass so the problem is
now now is the point where we figure out
what we're gonna do because this is a
real [__] slippery slope and every
time we say this [__] we're right this
is a slippery slope when Twitter and
every Tech platform let's not even pick
one every Tech platform is bending the
need of this [__] and it's [__]
getting to the point where it's getting
out of hands sure what if what if if I
can now any show that plays a clip of
Revenge hey guess what by the way
anybody who's hosting the Hassan [__]
clip of his finding us that sex
trafficking I was under duress when I
made that it's on you to prove I wasn't
right Hassan [__] should be kicked off
of Twitter but you know obviously I
don't want that but I'm just saying like
what is the difference here tell me what
the difference is being sex traffic is
now just like your pronoun if you feel
it you are that's it or you have no
proof I'm trans sex trafficked
for someone who sex traffic she can't
name one person that did it to her
um look like I said there's one solution
either print event in the quartering
sewer or World Star Hip Hop suits her
and they go to Discovery and she has her
whole life [__] spread out in court
unless that happens and somebody makes
an example of this [__] then people are
going to keep abusing the system
well I My worry is this it sucks that I
didn't get like if I'd gotten suspended
from Twitter or if something had
happened to me I would even been willing
to like explore like let's file emotion
let's start [__] with this broad just
for funsies and maybe we'll just go to
court and start subpoenaing documents in
her social media history and stuff and
you know that's the only way somebody's
gonna somebody's gonna have to now enter
into
some kind of a [__] litigation with
her but the thing is and you're right
and because you know why people think
that this is just this isn't just in a
light those are Eliza was terrible but
this isn't an Elisa blue problem this is
bigger than her now this is what our
right to criticize people if you're
right or you're wrong on any platform if
somebody comes up and goes I was sex
traffic in this video imagine if if
somebody that if somebody that we had on
in one of our videos
of anybody all right is Sarah Gonzalez
imagine Sarah Gonzalez out of nowhere
goes that interview with them uh
actually I was sex trafficked and then
our episode goes down and we get kicked
off of everything is that what it takes
is that what it takes going around
telling people oh I don't hope not I
like her she's really nice imagine yeah
it's just like it was the most
uncomfortable I've ever been that might
be true but you are not sex trafficking
and I've sat in a movie theater next to
Elijah Shaker bro I was drinking I
almost [__] choke that was a good
line
right
that's very true
um allegedly no I mean I'm sure she sat
next to him in a theater like that's not
a lie I didn't say anything else
hey you know they need to work with him
he he had a Hong Kong red dragon camera
and I almost pissed myself because it
was like a red dragon camera is so
expensive
holy [__] [__] she's everyone I hated
in film school like yeah you have an
expensive camera and your dad's a
producer but you [__] suck yeah but
meanwhile I knew people that filmed
really great stuff on [__] on on their
Nokia so apparently a fair and balance
by the way who's whose thing is coming
out here in a in a I think today or
tomorrow bro you've seen the pictures of
that chick when she was younger yes I
[__] did
did you see her joke but her joke was
funny
traffic when I was on the ball yeah and
I clicked I was like whoa yeah so um
apparently uh Katie Herzog has an audio
recording of an interview shooter with
Eliza blue and I haven't played this yet
but people said we have to listen to it
so let's check it out
I mean I I don't know if I mean for me
to tell my story at length uh is gonna
take a while I don't even I don't even
need that
Katie Herzog is asking her about her
story to kind of like you know what
happened you know so I know the basics
of your story because I've listened to
your podcast so I'm trying to figure out
exactly what the question is
yeah I know she's so defensive right
like when people lie I can ask you the
question
I didn't agree to this all I agreed oh
my God is Katie Herzog sex trafficking
her in real time
call Corey Feldman you know the problem
yes you know the problem was Katie
didn't give her half the super chats
you know what
by the way can we also make sure that we
call grifty award-winning Eliza blue I
don't give a [__] the votes say she won
well okay sure that's totally fine but
can I just kind
of questions or email you the questions
and you can decide who's this guy Katie
Sir I've never seen the dude it's like a
Michael Sarah type yeah he looks like uh
he looks like a [__] Elliot Roger
type looks like a millennial looks like
a millennial like non-binary version of
Jimmy Olsen oh yeah like if they were
gonna cast a new Superman movie yeah
this would be Jimmy Olsen because you
know it's a guy or a girl I just don't
answer or not
I mean did you did you ask Amanda in
advance to do that no I told her that I
wanted to ask you about the Twitter
stuff and about your own story okay so
you
deceived Amanda didn't tell her why are
you so just listen to her and also I
want to say this Katie Herzog is
probably like just up left this bag of
[__]
uh I'm sure she's no fun but
she's not being like inappropriate she's
just going like God I just want to hear
your story
and it seems to be a problem there yeah
that's a good point like she she gets
she's not being like no you [__] I
think you're lying she's just like no I
just felt like you would maybe tell me
your story I did not agree to tell my
story well Eliza listen to us this is
coming from both of us I'm sure speak
for Mercer too listen [__] we think
you're lying
no a survive guys
your Survivor all right I've been asking
her about her personal trauma no I I I I
that's not that's not what happened I
said
wow she didn't do anything to do with
her for this like this was a that's what
I mean really weird response I love
signing against female journalists yeah
don't get me wrong by default don't get
me upset yeah but there's still nothing
out of line yet
literally asked Elon Musk is defending
this crazy [__] how do you like that
I don't say he's not his silence is
defending her sir here I'm going to read
I'm going to read
I'm gonna I like you said Katie's
probably some sort of leftist stupid
idiot by the way I'm gonna do the Hassan
[__] thing and go
I don't think Katie would like us no I
don't think she'd be however she's
keeping her cool and being like look I'm
just trying to ask you a goddamn
question here and can I say Katie zerhog
looks more like Shaggy than the new
Shaggy and Mindy Kalin show yes
good I would be happier with Katie
Herzog playing the role yeah rock roll
rock roll it like some food go
to the message that I sent you scoop I
was just asking about your whole like
sex trafficking story man
squinks like hey Eliza
oh Rocky I think this business let's see
who she is pull her mask off it's
frosted this picture's lying
he's been suspended on Twitter oh no I
would have gotten away with it if it
wasn't for that damn defango
be honest in advance because I I won't
because there are times when I feel cool
about talking about it and there's other
times when I don't I'll read you the
message that I said I also kind of like
it the music underneath is Eiffel 65 the
blue song that's playing it's kind of
weird
um
you're not listening to me
because that brings me clout I'm not
comfortable of explaining why I deserve
the cloud yeah I'm not here to explain
to you why uh I'm actually valid
introduce yourself Eliza my name is
Eliza blue I'm a sex trafficking
Survivor oh tell us your story what's
with all the questions
true so you're gonna say PTSD you think
both
[Music]
I didn't know she worked with that
department and you know what I think
you're a cool person I uh why
I always have and I know you're cool
with Tim Dylan and I I would have
appreciated weird name drop
um Tim Dillon named Rock what was that
about
and stuff and you know what I think
you're a cool person I always have and I
know you're cool with Tim Dylan and I I
would have appreciated a little bit more
dude it's the little things that people
do that apparently North North Side CA
says Herzog writes all of Tim Dillon's
jokes is that true I don't know
I mean that's obviously sounds like a
joke that's funny
jokes please tell me that's not true
because it probably it probably is right
you're not listening to me I here's what
I said to her I said I'm interested in
the Twitter changes as well as I said it
was interesting her history as a
Survivor that is what I told him
Herzog have adult braces
I have no idea
she blooped out on you
is that a thing I have no idea oh maybe
it's blue it's trying to turn it can I
ask you the questions it's been a long
few days now she's tired no she's very
tired you know advocating was exhausting
braces but Gina Davis amounts of gum
dude making okay that explains it making
all your money on Twitter is hard
[Laughter]
for sleeping having titties and cash app
is so exhausting and did you know that
Elon waved the Eight dollar fee all I
had to do was blow it
uh allegedly I don't know if they had
sex
but he's [__] crazier
we always ask him the same question what
is your central strategy for defrauding
people they all say this they put the
music get them under the ether Under The
Ether ether is a heightened emotional
state where you're no longer thinking
rationally but you're reacting
emotionally and this explains why so
many people actually fallen for this
stuff say How could somebody that smart
fall for this it's not their intellect
that's engaged when they make that it's
their boner in this situation I know I
know what you're saying here but it's
their bonus it's their boners the things
that people do for women on Twitter is
[__] hilarious because they get
boners it's for boners